complications arising from surgical
procedures caused by faulty devices are
rare but can happen especially as there
are some 25,000 companies trying to
place their products on the European
market in 2011 the PRP breast implant
scandal where cheap industrial silicone
was put into implants for thousands of
women to undergo surgery to have been
removed incidents such as this were
proof that legislation on medical
devices used in all types of medical
procedures ranging from surgeries of
diagnostic examinations needed an
overhaul Parliament gave its full
approval to a preliminary text in 2014
we need clear picture and we need the
possibility to give to all the patient a
clear view of what we are going to
implant in their body in terms of
medical device in the past we have no
security not a process of authorization
of the devices obligations will be
placed on manufacturers to ensure safety
as well as random inspections on devices
patients and doctors will also be given
information on implants used to increase
traceability last autumn final
negotiations between Parliament and
member states began the two institutions
agreed to place a legal obligation on
the EU Commission to draw up a list of
devices that cannot be reused but they
use executive has some reservations they
want a negative list where one not to
have the possibility to repossess some
devices it is estimated that by 2060
there will be double the number of
people aged over 65 years old and so
ensuring medical devices are of the best
quality is of utmost importance